we'll start with Eileen over in South
Bend Indiana
hi Eileen how are you hello mr. Ramsey
it's wonderful to hear your voice and to
get to ask a question certain well I'm
doing okay but I could be better
I am in a situation where the company I
work for closed down in August and I'm
looking for work I would like some ideas
on out-of-the-box ways to go about
searching for that next job when I
cannot really relocate okay or something
and I have been looking online I've been
I work in graphic design and I have been
utilizing some of the websites trying to
drum up some freelance work that way and
it's just not not the results are not
what I had hoped for yet
Asha what why can't you relocate my mom
is in a nursing home about 40 miles away
okay
are you single yes okay how are you
eating well we're going to limit but
again that brings a bigger question I do
have death Barinholtz credit card debts
potholes because unemployment doesn't
cover that right now you were in graphic
arts what were you making in graphic
arts um about 30 okay all right so you
need to replace that income as a
freelancer or some other way right yes
or a different line of I've even been
low trying an administrative assistant
or customer service but I know customer
services use beef amidst ik for a lot of
no more paying jobs and it's office work
that I had thought of not I I would not
be a good cashier okay I work with me I
can do other things
gotcha Chris what thoughts have you got
yeah I think that's good that you know
what you don't want to do I think that's
really important I would say I tell you
step back a little bit and ask yourself
this might be a good season for you to
think through what do you want to do
from here on out
Eileen how old are you older than I wish
to be yeah
I'm assuming that two years ago I would
have um you know a lot a lot more
possibilities and I think that is my
challenge I'm at that tipping point
where the age thing could be again
me big-time right now how old are you um
I'm a little past 55 okay okay good all
right well I think I'm 55 I'm not that
worried about I don't think my
opportunities are gone yes sir yes
fifty-five years young yes just a lot
more experience than the rest of us I've
been told my voice and I you know don't
drink those folks oh I do have a young
voice but you know it's just once people
meet me they know I'm not 25 okay
Eileen if you want all your will you
know your relationships your friends and
maybe at your church or I I am I
both churches two different communities
both Church family anyway have a lot of
people crazy for me
any leads there uh not nothing live yet
I've had I've had two interviews but
nothing has materialized you to a job
that that would work yeah here's the
thing most people get a job where they
know somebody and it's not that you
quote the old saying like somebody says
it with their lips tuck out you've got
to know somebody but you really do got
to know somebody not because not because
they have power and if you don't know
important people you're up a creek
that's not what it means what it means
is is that those somebodies get your
resume out of that huge stack of other
applications and they at least get you
looked at
I mean we even have friends we had 134
people this year so far and we even have
friends email me or call me and say hey
would you interview somebody I'm going
noop I don't do interviewing but I'll
let my guys interview them and I won't
promise you nothing past that but I will
promise you that they at least get
interview because they knew me or if
they know Chris or they know Chris's
wife with the church she works at they
can come to Holly and go hey Holly can
you at least get me an interview get me
a look and then after that it's up to
you but you need to really do what Chris
was saying and think back through your
network and make a good list of those
folks because it could be that that your
nephews soccer coach is it knows
somebody that is your next employer and
or might be your next employer that kind
of a thing I don't know what it is but
that's that's the way you need to think
about it and you just really need to
rack your brain on that and
everyone know you're looking and hey can
you help me get in the door or you find
a company you start targeting some
certain companies you'd like to work for
and then you put the word out who knows
somebody that works in that company and
so I'm going to send you two books to
read immediately I want you to read them
completely before you watch a single TV
program as soon as they hit your box one
of them is called start and the other
ones called 48 days to the work you love
by Dan Miller and both of those books
will be very instructive for you and get
you started on the right path on this
that's very important lastly I'll do
this I have seen people have experienced
have some success doing this and this is
a weird one offer them a free test drive
I will come in and do graphic arts for
you for two weeks for free to show you
that I'm a rock star to show you that
I'm a big dog that I'm a thoroughbred
that I can get my work done and I'll do
I'll do to work I just I want to intern
for free just to show you and I know you
don't even need somebody right now but
by the time you see my work for two
weeks you and you see my work ethic and
my cheerful attitude you won't visit you
won't be able to resist hiring me but
I'm going to come in and give you two
weeks worth of work and just just show
off for you and you know you'd be amazed
the people that they say they say do
what because nobody wants to do that
because what that indicates is you were
willing to add value to the organization
and adding value to the organization is
what every employer is looking for
whether they say it out loud or not
they're saying I'm going to be paying
you thirty thousand can I make more on
what you produce than thirty thousand if
I can't then I'm losing money having you
around Chris you ever done that one yeah
and I you know I think it's you know
when you're a little bit younger they
call it interning but I think as I lean
as you as you go into this decision I
think instead of looking for a job you
are looking for a fulfillment how you
can add value is what Dave said and I
think you want to think impact before
income so how that's a good line that's
my tweetable look at you sing sing well
having an impact before income yeah I
think if you want to impact and add
value to people's lives that income will
come it's exactly right
and that's the right order to do it
that's how can I
bring impact my income if I where we say
around here is you helping up people you
don't worry about money
if you help enough people you don't have
to worry about money Zig Ziglar used to
say if you open up people get what they
want you'll always have what you want
that's another way of saying it as well
yeah so there you go Chris Brown joins
me from Chris Brown's true stewardship
this hour answering your questions with
me this is the Dave Ramsey show you guys
would be so rich so fast and be able to
do so much not only for yourselves and
for your family but for others
you